Knowing ISIL's desire to destroy modern human lives,
it's a natural extension for them to destroy cultural identity as well.
Countless invading armies have done the same throughout history.
We know that ISIL is profiting from the looting of sites,
but we don't know the scale.
This means that any object purchased on the market today
from the Middle East
could potentially be funding terrorism.
When a site is looted,
it's as if a puzzle already missing 90 percent of it pieces
has had the rest obscured beyond recognition.
This is ancient identity theft writ large.
We know that there are two kinds of looting going on:
looting by criminal elements like ISIL,
and then more local looting by those that are desperate for money.
We would all do the same to feed our families;
I don't blame the local looters.
I blame the middlemen, the unethical traffickers
and an international art market
that exploits often ambiguous or even completely nonexistent laws.
We know looting is going on on a global scale and it's increasing,
but presently we don't have any tools to stop it.
This is beginning to change.
My team and I have just completed a study looking at looting in Egypt.
We looked at open-source data
and mapped the entirety of looting across Egypt
from 2002 to 2013.
We found evidence of looting and site destruction at 267 sites,
and mapped over 200,000 looting pits.
It's astonishing.
And putting that data together --
you can see the looting pits marked here.
At one site, the looting got bad from 2009, 2011, 2012 --
hundreds and hundreds of pits.
Putting all the data together,
what we found is that, contrary to popular opinion,
looting did not start to get worse in Egypt in 2011 after the Arab Spring,
but in 2009, after the global recession.
Thus, we've shown with big data
that looting is fundamentally an economic issue.
If we do nothing to stop the problem,
all of Egypt's sites will be affected by looting by 2040.
Thus, we are at a tipping point.
We are the generation with all the tools and all the technologies
to stop looting,
but we're not working fast enough.
Sometimes an archaeological site can surprise you with its resilience.
I am just back from the field,
where I co-led a joint mission with Egypt's Ministry of Antiquities
at a site called Lisht.
This site dates to the Middle Kingdom of Egypt between 2,000 and 1,750 BC.
The Middle Kingdom was Ancient Egypt's Renaissance period.
After a time of intense internal strife and environmental challenges,
Egypt rebounded
with an incredible resurgence of art, architecture and literature.
It's a favorite period of time to study in Egypt,
because it teaches us so much about how we can survive and thrive
after great disasters.
Now at this site, we had already mapped countless looting pits.
Lisht is a royal site;
there would have been thousands of people buried there
who lived and worked at the court of Pharaoh.
You can see this before and after; you see dozens of looting pits.
North Lisht.
This is in South Lisht, before and after.
When we first visited the site,
we could see the tombs of many high-ranking officials
that had been looted.
Let me put into perspective for you what was taken.
Imagine a two meter by two meter area full of coffins, jewelry
and incredible statuary.
Multiply that times over a thousand.
That's what was taken.
So, when we started work,
my Egyptian co-director, Mohamed Youssef, approached me and said,
"We must work at this one particular tomb.
It's been attacked by looters.
If we don't do anything, they'll be back."
Of course I agreed, but I didn't think we'd find anything.
I thought the looters had stolen everything.
What we started to find were the most incredible reliefs.
Look at this painting -- it's just stunning.
We started finding engraved inscriptions.
And even the titles of the tomb owner --
he had titles like, "Overseer of the Army,"
"Overseer of the Treasury."
I began to have hope.
Maybe, just maybe we would find his name.
For the ancient Egyptians, having their name last for eternity
was their goal.
And then one day,
this appeared.
This is the name of the tomb owner: Intef.
You can see it written out here, in hieroglyphs.
Working together with my Egyptian team,
we had restored someone's name from 3,900 years ago.
(Applause)
Working together with my Egyptian colleagues,
we celebrated this moment of shared discovery.
What we were doing together was right and true.
We found this incredible false door, mostly intact.
On it we read about Intef and his inscriptions.
You can actually even see him seated here.
What I realized is that everything I had assumed about looted sites
had been proven wrong.
Every day on site we worked together with 70 Egyptians
as colleagues and friends.
In the face of so much hatred and ignorance
against those in the Middle East,
every moment on site felt like a protest for peace.
When you work with those that don't look like you,
or think like you, or speak like you,
your shared mission of archaeological discovery
erases all superficial differences.
What I learned this season
is that archaeology isn't about what you find.
It's about what you can prove possible.
Sometimes when you travel, you end up finding long-lost family --
not those with whom you share genes,
but a shared entry in the book of life.
This is Omer Farrouk, my brother.
Omer's a Gufti from a village just North of Luxor, called Guft.
Guftis are part of a celebrated tradition in Egyptology.
They help with digging and work crew organization.
Omer is my COO and CFO.
I simply couldn't do work without him.
One day many years ago, when I was a young graduate student
and Omer was a young Gufti who couldn't speak much English,
we learned, completely randomly,
that we were born in the same year,
the same month
and the same day, six hours apart.
Twins.
(Laughter)
Separated by an ocean, but forever connected
for Ancient Egypt is our mother.
I knew then we'd always work together --
not in my brain,
but in the part of your soul that knows not everything can be explained.
(Arabic) Omer by brother,
I will always love you.
(English) Omer my brother, I will always love you.
So, just before my first dig in Egypt,
my mentor, the very famous Egyptologist Professor William Kelly Simpson,
called me into his office.
He handed me a check for $2,000,
and said, "This is to cover your expenses.
Have a glorious adventure this summer.
Someday you will do this for someone else."
Thus, my TED Prize wish is partial payback, plus interest --
(Laughter)
for a great human being's generosity and kindness.
So, my wish.
I wish for us to discover the millions of unknown archaeological sites
around the world.
By creating a 21st-century army of global explorers,
we'll find and protect the world's hidden heritage,
which contains clues to humankind's collective resilience
and creativity.
(Applause)
Thank you.
So how are we going to do this?
We are going to build with the TED Prize money
an online, crowdsource, citizen science platform
to allow anyone in the world to engage with discovering
archaeological sites.
There are only a couple hundred of us space archaeologists around the world.
It is my dream to engage the world
with helping to find sites and protect them.
What you'll do is sign in, create a username --
note that this particular username is already taken.
(Laughter)
You'll take a tutorial and you'll start work.
I want to note at the outset
that in no way will be sharing GPS data or mapping data for sites.
We want to treat them like human patient data,
and not reveal their locations.
You'll then be dealt a card from a deck -- 20 x 20 meters or 30 x 30 meters,
and you'll be looking for features.
My team and I will have batch-processed
large amounts of satellite data using algorithms
in order for you to find things,
so you'll be doing really good science.
You'll then be starting to look.
What do you see? Do you see a temple?
Do you see a tomb? Do you see a pyramid?
Do you see any potential site damage or site looting?
You'll then begin to mark what's there.
And off to the side are always going to be rich examples
of exactly what you're seeing, to help guide you.
All the data that you help us collect will be shared with vetted authorities,
and will help create a new global alarm system
to help protect sites.
But it's not just going to stop there.
All the archaeologists with whom we share your discoveries
will take you with them as they begin to excavate them,
by using Periscope, Google Plus and social media.
A hundred years ago, archaeology was for the rich.
Fifty years ago,
it was for men.
Now it's primarily for academics.
Our goal is to democratize the process of archaeological discovery,
and allow anyone to participate.
Ninety-four years ago,
Howard Carter discovered the tomb of King Tut.
Who is the next Howard Carter?
It might be you.
By creating this platform,
we will find the millions of places occupied by the billions of people
that came before us.
If we want to answer the big questions about who we are
and where we've come from,
the answers to those questions do not lie in pyramids or palaces,
but in the cities and villages of those that came before us.
If we want to learn about the past,
it's time we inverted the pyramids.
Acknowledging that the past is worth saving
means so much more.
It means that we're worth saving, too.
And the greatest story ever told
is the story of our shared human journey.
But the only way we're going to be able to write it
is if we do it together.
Come with me.
Thank you.
(Applause)